It's not a live broadcast, but this is a TV
program.It's a make-believe with a script prepared by the broadcast writer.If you purify yourself
properly, the boy will be quiet with tacit
consent.The audience in the studio will applaud.
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah then let's have a blast here
It's been 30 minutes since the exorcism started.
Kutsu's mystery drawer is exhausted and I'm pumping up with ad-libs, but I'm going to make a
phone call and change the solo player
.
Let's call it a change in a half-baked place Play lake 30 minutes to create a live booth I'm already tired Oh, the lyricist yay
Well then, teacher, please.
You know, the actor
g
Color no no g Now, read
the atmosphere Even though we're creating the atmosphere of the program, the first voice
was deceived by everyone in the studio.
nice